hey leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal vier in einer zufällig
generierten welt in minecraft eure
ersten alter abonnenten dem ich hier
gerade diesen blöden typ hier weil diese
alle haben wollte man mich alleine
gemacht
ja du mit einem
danach alle menge werde ich mir für eine
farm aufbewahren fast ein bisschen gold
er hat sich wird mir einen goldhelm
einen goldenen kopf sieht wild den
helden bauen damit man den kopf zieht
was waren das bitte für logik kann ich
in diesem fluss zu springen
das darfst du nicht mein einfluss der da
habe ich gekauft da habe ich gekauft
aber ich versuche die rolex bringt wenn
ich sterbe dann lachen mich aus niemand
wo bist du denn du kannst du dir oben
guck mal wie ein eisberg war der server
das schärfste
ok jetzt geschafft gewesen
diakonie können die acht können dir egal
ob die passwörter babbels obligatorisch
notorische brücke war schön aussehen
erst mal nur ein stück also mache ich
gerade dann später mit alles schön
spielt das macht denn der tintenfisch
stelle tanzten die dubstep oder so sieht
das aus oder hatten grünen kumpel dabei
niedlich optimal vor mir geschafft
gräfenberg ich nehme sicherheitswahn
damit ein stückchen erst mal schöne
butter hier all diese butter sind brote
wahrscheinlich wieder stemmer foto ist
dann so ein komplettes stück butter
einfach nur wo bin ich hier lange über
die bonner alter alles vor schnelligkeit
in den nahkampf und ok diesmal will ich
schaffen mir meine sachen zu holen
du bist wenn du sagtest gagas die es
also gast
sure to be working for hinweis also soll
ich im bett gehen und man sich sogar
screen zu holen sondern wir wollen die
schon richtig kriegen das drehen das
heißt da will ich sagen ich war mal mein
kraft roboter damit man sich auch
versteht dann wollen eigentlich direkt
anfangen oder was ihr reich bauten
rollen portal so damit wir in den index
werden können uns jetzt genau damit wir
hier schon einen hohen skora zählen
können warte ich guck am besten einfach
weg dann dann sieht das auch keine ja
genau dafür mache ich das ja so ok ich
werde ich natürlich nicht aber ich
brauche noch ein feuerzeug das sprint
will help you ich weiß nicht ich die
mannschaft den sprung ich also ich hab
dir nicht nein ich bin zurück gelaufen
nein nein wir sind sie wir sind gute
sprünge sprinter jumper aber die karten
mögen uns einfach nicht
das ist der grund ja das ist der
absolute grund romani
ich bin aber auch schon lange nicht mehr
richtig gut gesprungen
da müssen wir zu sollen wir warten
vielleicht auch wir warten
nein wir müssen jetzt wieder zurück und
wieder ein einer kommt der gerade die
leitung waren haben uns zu sehr beeilt
ja dann schaffen wir das jetzt aber
schnell dir bin durch du schaffst das
nie im leben einmal den helm
ich frage mich gerade noch ich habe hier
was ich für ein hellblauer farbe mann du
sagtest jemand hält ja und die arbeiten
press panzer in diamanten hohe summe ich
bin fröhlich ausgerüstet du kannst gar
nichts mehr kommen her kann das
schwimmen fällt mir dann auf das darf
man ja glaube ich gerade nicht dass ich
dich geschlagen
ich hasse kag zehn sprünge hat sich in
wenigen städten an die klappt das doch
nicht ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die
gaskunden haben vielleicht bringt mir
glück macht das die spring ist und alle
in ordnung aber nur die kakteen ein
sprung hier der ist noch da und wir sind
so schlechte wortwitz reiser von dieser
typ den julians bockumer flames genau
san diego oder meinst du haft zum befehl
wenig ihn menschlich aber egal der weiß
hoffentlich auch wenn der bus sind
eine gute devise einfach hoch bauen
scheiß drauf wenn man stößt oder so nein
ich meine frauen in den himmel und
lichten
hier kann er trotzdem lover kommen dann
bin ich auf einmal parieren setzte aber
diese luft block mit lara ich hab jetzt
an weil so ein bisschen nur den rand
erforscht werden bett liegen ich schaue
dir ja ich mich auch ja dann einfach so
ein steak aus erd- oder so das müsste ja
gehen
ich habe gesagt ich mach einfach nicht
läuft läuft außer wenn die chips dann
wissen wir dann auch wenn ich sag's nur
denn wenn wir die jobs dann wissen wer
der babbels rpo
was willst du hast mich aber nicht wenn
das wird richtig erfolgreich dann hat
man zugleich spielt die musik einen sehr
fröhlichen song was perfekt passte denn
bilder werden
denn denn
denn reisen
ich finde nur eisen geht mir dir ich
wollte ja hab s college bruder peter
sind esther okay ich glaube dir kloeppel
ja ich glaubte ob es an meiner hand ist
ausgerutscht war nicht meins aber die
kokett april und eine hens controls und
wirklich die besten guck mal geil mal
rein
nein ich trau mich doch das trau dich
ich hab's level ja warum 328 damit habe
die übelsten sachen dabei jedes mal
durchmachen ja okay okay du warst
geboren
conny du wachst dem boden alter du gehst
durch und ich werd ich habe fast tot
das müssen wir noch mal üben immer wenn
ich irgendwas ok hallo ich hin
okay er hat apple ja wir haben bald
wieder weil wir uns so fett gefressen
haben hier jeder eine doppelbett
verhelfen
doch natürlich die geht ja auch gar
nicht anders
hilfe ist natürlich wieder raus du hier
stinkt's das geburtsfeier resistenz was
er das denn du hast gute leistung
hey hey ho okay wir müssen jetzt die
anderen auf jeden fall erstmal wieder zu
machen sonst schaffst du ich lebe noch
ich bin hier hilfe ich hab angst nur
wegen die us wirtschaft es geht für die
höhen zwischen wie das wasser gefallen
wollte ich gar nicht wo aber sind
was habe ich denn hier schwer okay noch
mal das war gut
es liegt hier wenn du willst kannst es
einfach nur liegt es wohl liegt es dass
mit den schlagen für übrigens eine blöde
idee du hast zwei pfeile im arsch bei
mir mein gott wartet dass ich einmal ein
foto machen
ok dann warte ich wenig seelig soll ja
warte website stehen
ok jetzt bleibt so stehen sieht er nicht
als jude weg alter schwede junge wussten
uns hallo ich blute
kennedy wieder die beiden
macspeech ich sterbe doch das macht
nichts ich habe klasse man halt keiner
jetzt cool wenn ich auf die sicht vom
sohn wechseln könnte wenn ich dann
verliere
wir schaffen das einfach mit dem kopf
durch die wand das ist immer die
bestmögliche so merkte dass fürs leben
natürlich das ist alles möglich und wir
schaffen das auch so richtig unmöglich
einfach immer gegen vallendar ist es
genau das richtige level für mich ich
will auch mal kaputt machen okay
facebook so du bist so blöd das tut mir
leid ich vergebe nicht verbrechen ich
wir sind viele hart so und weißt du was
noch hattest du weiter geht's los war
schloss ein gott 90 schwer so in seen
und das müssen wir jetzt eigentlich
schaffen weil das war ja vorhin nur so
weil der sohn wollte das unbedingt
der sohn wollte das unbedingt
kaputtmachen von daher haben wir das war
nicht so ganz geschafft wie ich das
wollte halt die fresse kann ich nicht
gleich unser kind los nein ich hätte
dich nicht du hast mir alles versaut bei
vw
kannst du das lagerfeuer lied sing setzt
euch ans lagerfeuer das lagerfeuer lädt
das lg rl et lid und geht noch viel
schneller denn erst dann darum sinkt ist
doch ganz einfach mit 1 234 energie
stellt darum denkt jetzt auch ganz
einfach mit 234 okay doch mal wie
protagonist dieses witzes rüdiger
giga.de also bis gestern nacht ein
konter geplatzt
was im ernst es gibt aber das ist mein
ernst haller
ach du scheiße ich habe mich verlaufen
im dunklen wald und wiese wo bist du wo
bist du ja im wald und zombie organische
wachstum ist so gut ich bin in summe um
gelaufen in dem mausoleum jetzt kommt
die knusperhexe die wirklich finden kann
man so vom kurs abkommen überhaupt nicht
so jetzt will ich ja doch nicht
versuchte weg zu finden zu wollen weil
ich so ungefähr war das war wartet das
war in richtung wichtig ob damit bist du
hier
ich beschütze was trägt man schreibt
aber warum
ach so und jetzt jetzt nicht dass wir
alle denken hey weg shui und gespielt
hat eine freundin und nein ich bin nicht
schwul das kann ich nicht sagen ich hab
ich bin ich mit ich bin auf den rat
gefasst
ich bin auf den rand tage oben gefallen
ich weiß gar nicht wie das passieren
konnte
ja ich komme nach
jetzt schaffe ich das moment ich bin
auch echt zu blöd zum montag fallen
aber das ist auch schon sieht richtig
heftig aus darunter fällt
spiral habe ich hätte da schon vorhin
rübergeflogen da kommen noch richtig
krasse sachen vollkommen jetzt schaffe
ich das
konzentration kompletter versuche jetzt
als der reporter nach unten
letzter versuch justins auch zu den
zuschauern ich glaube wenn wir jetzt
sage ich meine viertelstunde an einer
aufgabe hängen dann ist das schon uns
erlaubt das wären uns einfach mal tippen
wenn dann zwei logos geschafft haben ich
denke ich werde der typ während er es
nicht schaffen wird
noch nie seien alle hassen wir jetzt
schon dafür dass sie aber nichts
geschehen kriege fangen die ich auch
keine angst
es sieht bestimmt daran dass ich im bett
und alles mit möglichen mitgenommen habe
ich bin viel zu schweren adam g
ich hab das jetzt
ich weiß nicht wie kannst du nach einem
eingriff minister rhein gekippt
ich war das nicht ich mache nichts guck
ich guck wann der film war ja so wie
machen wir
wo bin ich alter was geht wenn man den
carlson abbaut
ich bin zur hauptbühne gegangen sag ich
mal war ich noch videomaterial brauchte
guck mich nicht die ganze zeit so
komisch ankommen
ich verschenke eine erde in noch jemand
ich dachte ich brauche keine pflanzen
hast gesagt hanf an pflanzen und
pflanzen habe ich gesagt ich hole
hanfpflanzen
theoretisch ist erotisch terroristischer
studie die komplette fläche pocken wir
hier hin wo ich ein guck mal mama wo
hingucker kopf gucken einfach rein und
ich konnte ja ich weiß was ich meine
kreative phase
pass auf ich schaffe das nein ich hab
das nicht ausreichte
direkt auf die alle zukommt
über mögliche alter
st